夫妻之间要有这种信任和共识，
我这一笔一笔都给你放在这儿，
你随时想查随时查，
你随时想知道余额，
我随时告诉你余额，
这种情况下我感觉就是尊重他，
在他自己觉得能力范围之内，
对他的父母，
对他的亲人的关照，
或者说人情的往来随他。
我跟我老公是那种相亲认识的，
我婆家那边的人就我介绍人，
跟我们牵的线，
我就是类似于那种闪婚闪育的，
我们订完了婚，
我就发现自己怀孕了，
当时孕盘挺大的，
就叫婆婆过来照顾我，
可能她就不愿意照顾我，
就会跟我做饭呢，
就弄了很多不愉快的事情，
吵了架之后，
她就跟我老公就跟我们说，
跟身的那个彩礼是借的，
要还，
吵半天的，
那个时候他的孩子也生下来了，
现在基本上就跟婆家那边的人不来往了，
我老公他是家里排行老三的一个姐姐，
他们都是八几年的吧，
我老公是87年八八年的，
十几岁的时候爸爸就意外走了，
他妈妈和姐姐跟他疏导的一些人生观啊，
还有就是帮他解决很多问题，
就是他比较依赖他们，
他的性格就是他自己不会做任何决策，
也不会去说任何事情，
在我跟国家之间是起了一个非常大的反作用的，
就是相当于会把矛盾越扯越大的那种类型，
今年三月份就已经闹到。
真的要去分开的这种情况了，
但是后面就是我想着孩子，
或者是说我跟他，
我能不能继续把自己全部改变，
把我整个人的认知，
各个方面的情况都改变，
把这个家庭经营下去，
因为我改变不了我老公嘛，
他的性格呀，
他的成长经验，
我都改变不了他，
他干什么工作的，
他是做机械的，
做机器人的，
大概一个月挣多少钱呀，
2万，
当时给彩力给了多少啊，
彩礼给了168000，
后来他说这个彩礼是借的，
是管谁借的呀，
跟他两个哥哥借的，
那这男生今年是多大啊，
37左右，
37岁，
照理来说他一个月工资2万块钱，
他自己得有点积蓄啊，
他是有很长一段时间是没有这么多工资的，
他是去年我们来了北上广深这边的城市，
他才拿了有这么多，
而且这个钱基本上就是我们一家人去用，
他是给我管的，
我要管小孩，
管家庭准备开销，
也就是说你呢，
想好好经营这段婚姻，
嗯，
现在孩子是多大了，
我宝宝一岁半了，
谁在帮衬你带孩子啊？
婆婆是在干啥呀？
婆婆在老家，
她基本上就是这5点农，
自己这边娘家是干啥的呀？
妈妈就是在家里带孙子，
她也是没有父亲，
也没有收入，
然后我爸爸是在帮我哥哥经营一家小饭店，
你。
这头是现在是在深圳生活还是在哪里生活啊，
在广州也没有买房子，
是不是没有买房，
我自己带了一套小房子，
当时出嫁的时候是想着把这个房子一起作为我们的老家庭的一个投入，
那你自己那个小房子是你自己挣钱买的，
还是你爸妈给你凑钱买的呀？
婚前我自己出了一部分，
我爸妈也出了一部分，
那个房子在哪里呢？
在武汉是全款了吗？
贷款那个房子现在值多少钱呢？
房子跌价了，
我当时买的时候总价也才六十几万，
那边可能打半折吧，
三十几万还差多少？
贷款呢？
34万的样子，
那等于是首付部分，
还款的部分都亏掉了，
对对对，
就靠你老公一个月挣2万块钱，
他是税后得到2万块钱还是咋的，
最后那我觉得你跟你老公想要过好的话，
你老公已经把钱都交到你手上了，
你每个月都要记账，
钱具体花到哪里了，
还是要勤俭持家的，
怎么说呢，
尿不湿有一块多一片的，
也有五六毛一片的，
是还是要勤俭持家，
给你和孩子买的衣服鞋子袜子啊什么的，
以实用为主，
就是有的时候亲戚朋友里面有年龄相仿一点的，
大一点的啊，
人家洗干净的衣服能用，
我们也可以用，
也没有什么大不了的，
因为确实啊，
你们抗风险的能力现在约等于零嘛，
没有任何抗风险的能力，
这是你老公一个月挣2万块钱。
那这2万块钱的话，
就得带8半儿来使，
又得租房子，
又得水电费，
又得物业费，
老了又得供暖费，
孩子，
所以我感觉在这个阶段的话，
咱们就是能省就省吧，
嗯，
对对，
然后我老公他姐姐是卖保险的，
刚开始他就毕竟的诱导我买保险，
但我还是给宝宝买了一份医疗险，
今年我又想给宝宝增加一点保险，
也是想通过自己存点钱，
大概在他姐姐那里买了，
给宝宝买了2万多的保险，
一年要2万的保费，
其实我坦率的跟你交啊，
我们中国人很多对于这个事情的观念是错误的，
其实我们首先要保的不是宝宝，
我们首先要保的是那个经济来源，
首先是要给你的老公，
他的意外险一定要有，
你知道吧，
他但凡出现什么意外的话，
保证你和宝宝能活得下去啊，
我老公买了保险，
他就前年跟我结婚之前，
他给就让他买保险，
但是他那个保险的身故受益人是他妈妈，
就是他所有的保险名下的身故受益人都是他妈妈和姐姐，
就是没有我们的名字，
我有跟我老公聊过这个话题，
要是你的话，
我直接给他投保，
我作为投保人，
她作为被保险人，
受益人，
我说了算，
如我说他特别介意这个事情的话，
也倒是可以先放一放，
但是我就是说跟姐妹们沟通一个理念的问题啊，
很多人都搞错了，
上来就是优先。
对，
宝宝宝不是的，
上来优先要保的是那个挣钱的，
是那个经济支柱，
是那个一旦出了问题全家就得崩塌的那个人，
上来要给他配齐了，
意外呀，
医疗这方面的呀，
都给他配齐了，
是这个意思啊，
然后你这头的话，
你从今天开始，
你听我的啊，
这一定是有好处的，
从今天开始记账，
就是他给我这2万块钱，
我一分一毫花到哪里去了，
我对他有所交代，
这样的话才能建立两口子之间的信任感，
就事已至此了，
就别往回倒了，
你日子想过好就别往回倒，
说当初你们娶我的时候，
彩礼都是借的，
那我就相当于自己把自己给娶了，
我跟你在一起，
我又带孩子，
将来我挣钱了，
还得跟你一起还债，
不倒这事儿了，
因为咱是想往好了过，
咱就别往回倒，
我有几个就是心里比较纠结的姐，
我家就是婆婆，
还有那些她的哥哥姐姐们，
她是跟我支不来往的，
除了她姐姐跟我就是推销保险，
我在她那里买的保险就是避免几年或者几十年，
我该怎样去跟他们保持这个关系，
我他们不来找我，
你也不想找他们，
我们肯定是过客过的，
但是我老公跟他们是有血缘关系的，
这后面几十年是避免不了他们会有接触的嘛，
我觉得这个事情就是尊重你的老公，
她妈妈过生日的时候，
他愿意送什么东西，
她送说过年的时候给他妈妈包个红包，
他就包在他能力允许的范围之内，
只要不负债，
不影响养孩子的情况下的话。
充分的尊重他。
当然，
当你每个月把这些开销12345，
房租多少钱，
水电费多少钱，
物业费多少钱，
取暖费多少钱，
孩子们尿不湿多少钱，
孩子吃奶粉多少钱，
孩子买衣服多少钱，
我买衣服多少钱，
你买衣服多少钱，
我俩电话费多少钱，
网络费多少钱，
当你把这些开支放在他面前的时候，
他自己心里得有个数，
他到底是要打肿脸充胖子，
说他妈妈过生日给8000，
还是说他要量入为出，
他妈妈过生日的时候意思意思的给个三五百，
这事儿都交给他，
但前提条件是我们夫妻之间要有这种信任和共识，
我这一笔一笔都给你放在这儿，
你随时想查随时查，
你随时想知道余额，
我随时告诉你余额。
这种情况下，
我感觉就是尊重他，
在他自己觉得能力范围之内，
对他的父母，
对他的亲人的关照，
或者说人情的往来随他。
我可能会觉得你给的多了，
但我聊死了，
我不说你去给，
给完了之后，
下个月这生活费够不够，
保险费够不够，
孩子啊，
吃饭够够，
你自己看着办，
就这意思啊，
星期事儿，
其实我也想明白了，
是按姐姐说的这样去做，
但是情感上我该怎么去调理自己的一个心态？
呃，
情感上你得有个盼头，
你这个盼头不是寄希望于说这个男人有多尊重我，
男人有多看到我的付出，
不是的，
我的盼头是什么呢？
当孩子大一点了，
3岁了，
哎哟，
我终于可以送托儿所了，
我就可以出去挣钱了，
我的安全感会越来越强了。
哎，
我的话语权会越来越强，
诶，
你得有这个盼头，
这日子才好过，
现在遇到的所有的困难都是暂时的，
现在遇到的所有的矛盾都是暂时的，
等到有一天我自己能挣钱了，
有很多困难矛盾都能迎刃而解，
你得每天有着这个盼头在心里，
你的日子才过得下去。
然时话就老公这一头的话，
就跟哄孩子是一样的，
我自己切身的感受啊，
姐妹们啊，
甭管她多大年纪，
她是20岁，
30岁，
40岁，
50岁，
还是60岁，
跟老公相处，
我自己的感受就是跟哄孩子是一样的，
道理是那样的，
我老公直接说有他吃的才会有孩子吃的，
就是他要先吃孩子才有的吃的，
然后说就我带孩子金贵，
就这样的话都是比比皆是的，
我说你这月这两块钱给我，
我我不要讲这种话啊，
就不讲这种话，
就只讲啊，
你老公你辛苦了，
你看我们现在全家都吃你的喝你的啊，
哎呀，
真是的，
你一定要健健康康的啊，
出门一定要注意安全啊，
任何时候我打你电话你一定要接，
要不然会担心的啊，
女孩子是一样的道理啊，
嗯，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
对，
不管怎么说的话，
虽然说他可能家庭条件不太好，
但是他现在挣钱能力已经超过了很多了，
已经超过很多人了，
他毕竟税后一个月能交2万块钱到你手里，
那相当不错了，
那就凭这一点来说的话，
人家就已经及格了，
就已经是超过及格分了，
所以就就得会想啊，
记得点赞关注。